hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
Monday August 10th
2022. I love saying that 22 it's almost
over ah cheese was sliding into the
holidays there
you go to your local grocery store
the pumpkins are out
you know gotta get a good one don't pick
it up by its stem Dorothy
Jordy oh I oh I told you not to pick it
up by this stem didn't I
I'm not coming down on you God you can't
tell her anything
you know she's on her third marriage
um it's probably because she grabs a
[ __ ] like that
um anyway you go into the the uh
uh you go into the [ __ ]
the grocery store you know what's
hilarious when all of a sudden it's the
holidays there's just sugar [ __ ]
right up at the front of the uh right at
the front of the store you come in
there's all all the candy for Halloween
the candy corns who the [ __ ] is still
buying that [ __ ] is beyond me
the Candy Corn is that like hipsters
buying that ironically to act like it's
like good candy or something like that
are there hipsters anymore have they
disappeared
um are hipsters like uh rollerblading
the one the the one fad
example that I always go to it's like
rollerblading
you know
there's plenty of other fads I could
it's like slavery
you know everybody was doing it and then
after the 1860s anything what I wasn't
doing that
I I bet black people were selling other
black people into slavery the same
justifications for slavery people use
for uh rollerblading
they don't
see this why stick with rollerblading
I keep it small on this podcast all
right just like my brain
okay
the same way if if you're in aviation
you you fly with within within your
limits
within limits of the aircraft and more
importantly your own limits
I like that more importantly your own
limits well then what if you like Chuck
Yeager and you take my little egg beater
up your [ __ ] limits are Way Beyond
my thank Christ you'll break it apart
ah Jesus I don't know what I'm talking
about oh I know you're going to the
grocery store
and they got all this sugar up front
right and it's that's all it's gonna be
it's just gonna be sugar and flour and
eating and [ __ ] and sucking it's
gonna be it's gonna be all of that
and
I think it's like that
you know obviously everybody loves the
holidays but I think that towards the
end of the year is one of the few times
that people
have the time to actually take stock in
what the [ __ ] is going on in their life
what is going on in this runaway train
of time that just keeps [ __ ] Cruising
past
and I don't seem to be getting ahead I
don't know what's going on and that's
like I think you know if you went back
into the history books if you looked
back and saw when the seeds for the
American Revolution happened I bet it
was between October and December you
know because there wasn't a bunch of
sugar laying around there wasn't any
candy corn or any M M's or any of that
[ __ ] right there wasn't any hair plugs
so Ben Franklin's sitting there you know
looking like David Crosby
with this dumbass glasses he's getting
older he still likes the ladies he's
getting deep in the cut you know and
people are sitting there you know he's
thinking like I mean how many more years
can I be this Jolly fat guy with the
kite and still get some [ __ ] you know
Pilgrim [ __ ]
this is all True by the way
oh
I need to have some sort of power
was he was he around then I don't even
know if he was did he when did he fly
the kite was it in the 18 it can't be in
the 1800s because they never they never
really got into the 1800s
when I was in high school they didn't
want to do all that [ __ ] and they come
completely ignored slavery they just
sort of were
and um
uh genocide
I got the I got the nice easy listening
you know they put on some Kenny G
they were taxing us too much so we
didn't know what to do
we got out of [ __ ] piece of paper
and now everybody [ __ ] signed it
oh then Crispus addicts died right
foreshadowing every Hollywood movie for
about 80 years
um the black character was gonna die
anyway plowing ahead here
yeah so I think like you know there's
something there's something about that
like the end of the year
I think initially it was like a
celebration I know there's a bunch of
History busting it was the end of all
the farming and everything was harvested
so they would have a celebration
this podcast is not about facts
it's about having an idea going with it
making up [ __ ] and hoping that people
believe it
that's what I like to do I like you know
instead of sending messages out in a
bottle I just send up false history
I send it out and I see if it comes back
to me I just want to hear how people
have Twisted it around
you know is that what you do build no
it's not what I do I don't know what it
is I do but I will tell you this they
got all this sugar and flour is up front
and now there's two different kinds of
pumpkins all right the kind that
supports America and the other ones that
need to get the [ __ ] out
no the um they have the smooth ones
and then they have
um
the ones with the the [ __ ] warts all
over them
and I always want to buy a wart one
because I always go on like uh
you know carvingpumpkins.net whatever
the [ __ ] they are tick tock
um
cantaloupe what the [ __ ] is it called
cafeteria it's the other one what's the
other [ __ ] social media I was
actually I did an interview on it with
Eddie brill
it was called uh begin with a C
and had something to do with like uh
people meeting together what would that
be a word what's a word
that means people Gathering to [ __ ]
talk but not really saying anything and
it begins with a c oh yeah social media
um I spelled it the Communist way with
the c
because I'm one of them Hollywood
liberals
um
yeah on those those sites where they
show the uh
the the [ __ ] warded up pumpkins like
like those are the ones that like people
turn into these crazy psycho old men
or like they can carve like predator or
something out of it and uh
I'm just not blessed with those skills
I'm a I'm not what the kids call I
believe a a BB Bill Burr basic [ __ ]
Bill Burr when it comes to pumpkins
you know
I don't have time now that I got the
kids so I'll just do the [ __ ] the
triangles and some [ __ ] up teeth but
um back in the day I was really into it
people was listening to this podcast
since the 2000s remember my AC DC
pumpkin they remember my Federal Reserve
pumpkin this there's pictures of it on
the internet you can find it
you know it's out there if you want to
hear the truth you know if you don't you
want to keep burying your head in the
sand
and keep listening to these these lies
from [ __ ] the man
then you know
I don't you know I don't even get
emotional about it you know why guys
because I'm above it
I'm above it
no I'm gonna watch some pumpkin carving
videos and I'm gonna try to take my my
pumpkin carving
up to the next level
really bill is that what you're doing at
54 that's exactly what I'm doing you
know why because I'm not going to be on
the road for the next three
[ __ ] weeks [ __ ] I am
uh let's catch you on the flip side
[ __ ]
um
it's my favorite line
from Bridesmaids
um catch you on the flip side
[ __ ]
um yeah I don't have to do [ __ ] my
daughter is off uh from school this week
so we're gonna do a bunch of daddy
daughter dates which basically involves
me uh taking her to all of these places
that everybody brings all their kids
it's so funny how it's like all worked
out now there's just these places to
take your kids you know when I was
growing up they just sent you outside
and you just met other kids and you kind
of came up with your own [ __ ] and now
it's just like um
you know they have like all of these oh
that [ __ ] last time I went I was
gonna fight with that [ __ ] dad
because his 400 pound [ __ ]
three-year-old
was hitting my kid over the head oh you
can't say anything to anybody's [ __ ]
kid
[ __ ] Gorilla Monsoon for I can't I
said I wasn't gonna make fun of his kid
I didn't want to do that but sorry
um
anyway so I'm going to be doing a bunch
of that [ __ ] uh um and then I got a uh
respectfully here I gotta give a shout
out to two amazing comedians that we
lost this month uh first off was David a
Arnold
um
just an incredible incredible
um
I don't know how to describe that guy
that guy was just like
his his energy and his Vibe like always
positive always up and I remember way
back in the day
um
we used to do this club
called uh it's now it's called The
Comedy Union it was called mixed nuts
back in the day forgive me if I already
did this but I don't care if I'm
eulogizing them twice
um
we used to this place mixed nuts
and it was and we were all roughly the
same age was me him
uh
Alex Thomas
and then that other guy what the [ __ ]
was his name he was incredible
oh his name came to me Daryl Heath
Daryl Heath and all three of them were
[ __ ] amazing amazing Comedians and I
went down there the white guy going down
to the club it was funny it was called
like mixed nuts because they wanted like
everybody to come down but it was uh
down in a neighborhood that you know
white people sort of drove by it didn't
stop
sounds kind of you know black oh [ __ ]
that's the club that was the club I went
up at and I was bombing for like [ __ ]
seven minutes straight
on a hot summer night and then there was
just nothing from the crowd and I just
heard this
big girl in the back just goes I ain't
laughed yet
[Laughter]
oh
oh that was a tough one now what I
thought it was a rough one anyway and um
David was kind of in and out of my life
uh because I ended up moving back to New
York and I lost touch with him and then
I came back in 07 ran into him
immediately hey you know like like
nothing ever happened and
um
you know just every time I met him he
was a better version of himself you know
a lot of people that you meet you meet
him that's who they are and then you
don't see him for 10 years and they're
that same person that just 10 years
older you know but he was always better
amazing husband and father I went to the
service beautiful service and um
you know his daughter went up there and
like the stuff she said about him I hope
someday my kids say about me because
um it was
it was uh
I don't know how to describe it it was
just like he did it he absolutely
crushed it as a dad and that's the most
important thing and he was an amazing
comedian so
David a Arnold I'll definitely be
missing him seeing him around the clubs
and then we had a legend we lost the the
great Judy tenuta who just was a total
original
and um I remember in the 80s when she
first broke it was like super super
super super [ __ ] male dominated
uh which was stupid because we you know
already seen all these other great
comedians you know
um from Joan Rivers to Marsha Warfield
but for some reason they just I don't
know
and it became so you know I was talking
to somebody about that where it just
became like this really like the 70s
were [ __ ] amazing as far as like
the amount of different kinds of sitcoms
there were
it wasn't just a bunch of white sitcoms
they had like the uh you know Sanford
and Son The Jeffersons Good Times
Freddie Prince had Chico and the Man and
then they had a lot of like you know it
you know Hollywood sort of balance cast
for back then but it seemed like it was
moving in that direction I don't know
what the [ __ ] happened it was like Bill
Cosby hit
and they did a sitcom around his act and
it became huge and you would think that
that would somehow that drove it to make
it more white like I don't know what
happened and all of this 70s [ __ ] went
away
and then by the 90s all the shows were
just trying to do friends which was just
like you know
six good-looking pouty white people in
[ __ ] huge apartments with awesome
clothes
um I don't know I'm kind of sweating
away getting back to Judy so all of that
[ __ ] was going on and then you had like
the like the kittens and the um
uh the dice Clays and all this whole new
sort of style of Comedy Eddie Murphy and
all of that stuff and in the middle of
all of that
she came out
and just absolutely [ __ ] killed
calling her audience pigs
and that she was their goddess and all
of that and just her delivery and
everything she just was a total like
original and I watched her before I even
started doing comedy and I remember
thinking like this person is is the real
deal so I wasn't you know she's not
somebody that I ever met unfortunately
and I wasn't aware that she was sick but
uh rest in peace and thank you for all
of your legendary stand up that you did
um and if you guys aren't aware of her
Judy tenu to check her out David a
Arnold check his stuff out
um both amazing amazing comedians that
we lost
um okay and with that let's get on to
bread and circus let's talk some let's
talk a little bit of football let's talk
uh car racing which I missed car racing
F1 I've missed all of it this year
congratulations to uh Sebastian Vettel
um seemed like one of the most
interesting seasons
as far as like I don't know what
happened with Mercedes this year
um
and Lewis Hamilton the guy got no wins
and had like only like six podiums so
um I wish I was you know I can go online
I'm gonna watch this season when I get
my my big break when I'm done with this
tour
I'm gonna watch the whole season and get
caught up because I feel like there's no
way he's gonna tolerate that and there's
no way Mercedes is going to tolerate
that and I think next year is going to
be [ __ ] even better than this year
because you know seeing all those
different names Perez and all of them
and that Ferrari kind of came back even
though every race I saw they were doing
great they seemed to [ __ ] things up but
um it seems good now like it's not just
like one team dominating everybody
um all right you're New England Patriots
as predicted
by uh uh uh Dave Portnoy absolutely
destroyed the lion State Portnoy came on
he said he tweeted he said that they're
gonna [ __ ] kill him
and uh might even have said they're
gonna win by 30 and they won by 29.
um
Patriots look great Zippy zappy whoever
our [ __ ] quarterback is I was flying
during it I caught like the last couple
minutes of it
um it's the first time I've seen the old
Pat Patriot uniforms where I didn't get
sick to my stomach I was actually
starting to think of like when when Tom
Brady used to wear them when they would
do that because whenever Tom would wear
me and my uh older brother would be like
dude I can't like this is making me sick
like one like we had like child sense
memory not that the teams were bad
because we had a lot of good teams with
that uniform but it was just we had
heartbreaking [ __ ] losses
um in that uniform so um
Patriots look solid man I mean I know
it's just the Lions but um
you know I was worried that you know
with our our backup quarterback that
this was going to be like a problem
and we were going to get smoked and I
don't know where we were going to go but
uh I think a lot of people are sleeping
on Belichick a little bit I think Tom
Brady is you know the good-looking dude
goes down to [ __ ] Tampa wins the
Super Bowl and everybody just kind of
went like oh it was him
it was all of him it was both of them so
um The Mad genius is up to his uh
is up to his Mastery of football again
so um and I'm gonna have time to [ __ ]
sit down and watch I did tape that game
so I'm gonna watch it today
that's how excited I sound just to have
I I've been on the road every single
[ __ ] weekend
since the beginning of August
um so I this nice little window here is
great I watched a bunch of playoff
baseball
when I was on the road uh particularly I
you know I was keeping an eye on that
Cleveland Tampa Bay
uh series uh congratulations to the
Cleveland Guardians
the walk-off Homer and what the 15th
inning
um that's amazing the Seattle almost
said Seahawks Seattle Mariners making
the playoffs for the first time and God
knows when the Toronto Blue Jays blowing
eight to one lead that would have closed
it out
last year was the trailer this year is
the movie all of that hype and all of
that [ __ ] all of those Toronto fans
hoping for a playoff series victory
well they did have the basketball they
did win a championship so at least they
got that because that's one of those
things where I was just going like Jesus
Christ what the [ __ ] more can they do to
Toronto sports fans
um but you got to give it up to that the
Seattle Mariners
um
I watched the beginning of that game
well I was like all right it looked like
Toronto's going to win then I had to go
do a show
and I was working with Nate Craig who
you got to see him man he [ __ ]
murders
um
he he was going like he goes dude you
watch that [ __ ]
Toronto game he goes they're gonna blow
it he goes it's ten to nine my kind of
[ __ ] is attended it was eight to one I
watched like the first five innings
right before all the fireworks started
and uh and one of the worst things ever
is the shortstop running out to the
Outfield looking over his shoulder while
an outfielder is coming in I remember uh
Johnny Damon had a brutal Collision
[ __ ] cheekbone was all swollen up
um
oh Jesus uh and then the San Diego I
watched that whole game I watched the
San Diego Super Padres close out
the [ __ ]
New York Mets I saw the first game too I
missed the second one I saw the first
one
where Matt Scherzer went out there and
uh
I mean just one of the most colorful
guys in the [ __ ] game they cut to him
out in the bullpen you know
and he had a look on his face like you
know like when you're pulling the
driveway and you were out too late and
your dad's standing there
[Music]
and you're like should I just back up
and drive to another house this guy
looks like he's gonna [ __ ] murder me
he looked like someone was gonna was
breaking into his house and was going to
attack his family that was the [ __ ]
look on his face and I was like holy
[ __ ] I gotta see this guy and the Padres
went up you know they got a single and
then some guy hit a [ __ ] two-run
Homer and they kind of lit him up poor
guy got booed anytime an old guy gets
booed I mean you know there's no way
that I can't relate to that being an old
fella
um
anyway but uh I'm excited for the next
round of playoffs if you're a Yankee fan
I would think that you were pretty
excited that Tampa Bay got knocked out I
think they match up well against you and
uh you know it's nice that Toronto's up
but you guys kind of owned them this
year didn't you I thought you guys did
great they [ __ ] well everybody killed
my Red Sox this year but Toronto
particularly really [ __ ]
was kicking our ass this year but um
it's kind of cool man Seattle Cleveland
Houston the Yankees and then when he got
on the other side you got the Dodges the
Braves the Padres and who won the
Phillies uh St Louis I don't even know
I don't even know
um all right so anyways that's that's
all the sports stuff I want to thank
everybody that came out and Windsor
Minneapolis and Des Moines
um
winds are such a a fun place this casino
I do it's literally right across this
river that leads into uh Lake Erie I
believe
and it's kind of cool you're just
sitting there
and the view I had was a cross of it
looking in from Canada across the river
into America looking at Detroit and I
was kind of feeling like this must have
been like what it was like you know East
Berlin West Berlin going like how the
[ __ ] is that another country right over
there
and I can do
you know all of that [ __ ] over there I
can't do I can't do it here and vice
versa just because of that [ __ ]
stupid River and all of this [ __ ]
um
unfortunately I didn't get to spend any
time in Detroit one of my favorite
places but I did have a great time in
the casino and the crowd was awesome and
then the next day we went to uh we went
to Minneapolis
and uh oh look who's here everybody I
kept it quiet
because everybody was asking when is she
coming back the triumphant return
for the absolutely lovely the lovely
Nia's back everybody yay what's going on
Wow how are you gorgeous
you look great come on come on over here
because I was actually getting ready to
start talking about Minneapolis so when
you go to Minneapolis now you know I've
been going there for uh for like I don't
know 20 years on the road when I first
started working they were doing colleges
driving up to Duluth
um going to the Mall of America riding
the [ __ ] Roller Coaster by myself
wait I want to go to the Mall of America
is it worth like it's I feel like for
kids right like I feel like the kids
would like it they have an indoor skiing
situation in there right it's very water
park or something if I could describe it
it's very Dallas
I don't know what that means Dallas is
is like you know it's the best because
it's the biggest bigger is better so
that it's just it's stupid I think
there's two comedy clubs in there or
something it's insane really yeah and
there's this everyone in Houston is
really pissed at this right now San
Antonio is like [ __ ] Dallas oh yeah yeah
they don't I don't like boo yeah they
don't like Dallas they don't like Dallas
they're like we're all like the super
like rich people are yes or I would say
push people everywhere but I don't know
I don't know enough about Texas but just
the vibe I would say Dallas is it's not
Hollywood it's more like Orange County
okay I was just about to say because at
one point I think they were gonna do a
real housewives of Dallas and they
scrapped it so I feel like oh wait no
they did no they should have no no they
did they had Real Housewives of was that
in Dallas I think so I don't know honey
and I think they scratch it because
there was some racist [ __ ] going on but
anyway uh shout out to Dallas
well anyway all these years going to
Minneapolis like
you would forget that Prince was from
there because there was nothing there
but now that he's passed and his next of
kin are kind of like I guess the next of
kin of Elvis where all of a sudden Elvis
was like on cuckoo clocks you know a
tick tock tick tock man I'm like hey man
it's two o'clock
we get off the plane there's a prince
store now
well at the airport like a Hot Topic but
it's all print stuff oh I don't think he
would have no no but I mean but as a fan
I'm a fan oh [ __ ] they got a bunch of
print stuff in there it was kind of nuts
though because they had the one t-shirt
they had like his symbol when he was
getting [ __ ] over by the artist and
all uh uh getting [ __ ] up the labels
and everything he's like I'm the artist
and all of that
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
um which was super annoying as a fan I'm
not going to call you the artist your
prince so The Artist Formerly Known yes
as the artist
um anyway he was right though he was
right but he could have done it unless
like I know he's passed away Prince away
oh yeah I Am the Artist no Prince no
Prince Lander that sounded like a failed
like comic book superhero
um anyway so they had that symbol on
like a t-shirt being sold at the airport
and all of that so anyway but now it's
cool is you go down the street there's
like murals of them and stuff I saw that
and when we went to go do the venue the
tag at Santa uh we drove by and it was
like so it was incredible downtown so
you got to go to Minneapolis man
you would okay you got to go the next
time I would because I really want to
experience that part of like the prince
history too because I'm just like the
hugest fan uh why are we doing it like
this where are your microphones oh
there's something going on with my
computer I don't know oh okay I don't
know so anyway the uh there's always
something going on that means I clicked
the wrong [ __ ] button and now I can't
get something to go away so I I don't
know so anyway uh we were driving to the
venue and I just see like there's all
these music spots
and uh like titty bars and [ __ ] was this
the same thing they all kind of when you
do like three cities in three nights you
kind of like overlap you can't remember
but I think it was like that and then
you [ __ ] uh it was all like lit up
and [ __ ] all like like the Bullwinkle
shows like that I didn't have no idea
they had this downtown scene so we went
by this one music venue I was like man
what is that place that place looks cool
and it was the place where they shot
like purple rain is that called First
Avenue yes First Avenue so I was like
man I want to [ __ ] go in there
so uh Kenny ended up setting it up and
they gave us a quick little tour they
had the replica of the of the Purple
Rain motorcycle and then I just poked in
like the backstage area I think they
filmed all of that you know when Morris
Day stops and comes back has a family
um that's somewhere else I think that
was shot somewhere else but like you
went in and it was like
it took me back to like [ __ ] 82 or
like 83 when Little Red Corvette came
out and all of that it was so [ __ ]
cool it almost looks the exact same but
um it smelled like the classic like
music venue of struggle yeah smelled
like a rehearsal space wholesale
cigarette smoke yeah yeah yeah so the
walls you will never be able to get that
yeah it was [ __ ] awesome it was
awesome and I want to thank everybody
over there for uh hooking us up and then
we went to Des Moines
and uh got some great food at this place
it was like the bait and tackle thing I
got a
I got a beef goulash total Midwest what
is that it's [ __ ] goulash goulash you
know it's like uh working class food
it's like a pasta with the beef in it
there's it's a white pasta
um well this it's it's beef with with
egg noodles almost like oh okay yeah
yeah and then like a white cream sauce
so and it's one and it's one of those
things it's like mac and cheese it's
sort of like endless well I guess all
dishes are like that where you can kind
of like
you like one of the classic
African-American side dish right there
you know it's like collard greens except
that yes please please white explain it
to me oh I got it I got it yeah so
goulash yeah so like it's good
it was [ __ ] delicious it was it was
Heavy though it was heavy like hey man
it was Heavy oh boy let me tell you I
didn't have to [ __ ] eat for like the
next uh you know I didn't eat till like
the next day put it that way but right
we went there and then we went to this
uh coffee place I forget the name of it
was also delicious so they had like this
great food scene there Des Moines really
underrated City definitely has uh some
scary people there it was definitely
that the meth hangover a little bit is
going on there
there's a reason why they didn't shoot
The Hangover in Des Moines but I hear
it's beautiful
is it beautiful there or am I think of
Idaho I think of another eye state that
people are like it's gorgeous probably I
if there's people out here it's probably
like they're all about Idaho Montana and
Wyoming right and then you move out
there as a Hollywood producer and then
you like buy like Rancher gear and then
you go in town with your East Saint
Laurent cowboy boots
yeah howdy partner and they're looking
at you with like real cow [ __ ] on their
feet like oh boy please don't turn this
into Aspen right okay please don't make
me not be able to afford that but you
know that's you know that's how it works
you know that's just basically how it is
you know people who are rich [ __ ] up a
neighborhood and then we go to a new
neighborhood we uh we force people out
or whatever so that's what we do put
that up but we I mean white people yeah
okay you just have to deal with it man
that's that's that's my vibe I was
actually I have a meeting later on
tonight with some other white people who
are going to figure out what
neighborhood we're gonna [ __ ] up next
um sorry
um all right let me do uh let me do some
reads here
really quickly and then we're going to
get into what I really wanted to do with
you which is the the advice and all of
that stuff because people always ask me
like when's Nia coming on
literally literally a year don't you
think no it's definitely been too long
yeah I mean did I do it with you during
the pandemic
or no because I was just with baby and
everything
I don't remember with baby meaning like
with him nursing I was with child no
like there's a lot of child things that
you know what I don't like is it's
especially with all like the ketchup
Predator [ __ ] out there why do they
still call it child rearing
child rearing rearing is it yeah isn't
that just raising basically like let's
just say that instead of bringing up his
[ __ ] Dairy out there no one thought
that but you
no one ever thought about that's what I
thought when I first heard it like yeah
we've been doing some child rearing it's
just like God I don't like that image
William what it says rear right rearing
it says right there the word rearing
well yeah I'm dumb
I'm not dumb maybe I [ __ ] I'm looking
at it from a different angle all right I
am a meathead that is that is it look at
look at my little room out here look
what's on the wall Nia does anything
here suggest I read a book
I have a Patriots helmet you have some
books on your bookshelf though all right
let's look at what they are okay let's
see Led Zeppelin Rick Flair John to be
the man you got to be the man you got to
beat the man Rick sucks uh The Comedians
sex drugs and rock and roll
um hmm Bill Walsh finding The Winning
Edge a buddy of mine gave me that book
as a joke because I was talking about it
and I still I it's fascinating Bobby Orr
ESPN New Orleans Sports AFL
oh the history of AFL Barrett now
there's a book is that the American
Football League yes
well I figured you have like and then
you have a few things on Richard Pryor
huh
um I stay in my Lane Led Zeppelin 1975.
oh no you have that book great or what
was it 10 great daddy daughter dates or
something yeah that was a gift very cute
and I just put it up there I haven't
done that yet I was thinking of where is
that book I gotta get it it's on the top
mm-hmm okay so you know I started
looking at a lot of it was like arts and
crafts and I'm just not in the glue
I'm not in the glue I don't want to like
I don't want to like put things together
I don't want to do that no I don't want
to do that I would rather go out and
like drive around in my truck exactly I
want to take them places I want to take
them to like make stuff with them that's
not really my thing I want to go to like
a car show I gotta oh yeah you know you
know yes there was a there was like a
monster car thing that was like earlier
this year if you were out of town but it
would have been a great thing if they
got the headphones and stuff and you too
yeah our son absolutely loves obsessions
trucks and motorcycles do you know yeah
do you know in uh in Des Moines they
have this ridiculous truck museum uh
it's uh Interstate 80 Truck Museum and
it's like all like tractor trailers like
the big [ __ ] ones that that our son
goes nuts for that's so cool um he
always goes whoa big truck
um his favorite thing from uh cars is
Mac he always does you know he wants to
watch that movie Cars every day I know
he's such a little boy is he wearing a
Julian edel Edelman Jersey right now I
think he is she is who got him dressed
this morning I did
well there you go but I got to give a
shout out to a comedian Al doucheb was
the one who gave us that
um all right let me do a little bit of
the reads here look who it is everybody
oh zip
screwed up
Nia did you know that there are
currently over 2.4 million podcasts in
the world what yeah well there's seven
billion people oh Jesus you know you
need 2.4 of them to explain things
including the one you're listening to
right now and it takes a a team of
people to bring these podcasts together
I don't know about that needless to say
hi Andrew endless there you go it takes
a team of Andrew theemolists to upload
it uh needless to say then why are you
saying it hiring the right people for
these roles is important and whether
you're hiring for a podcast or a growing
business there's only one place that
makes it easy OH ZIP
there you go uh
it's the first time I did a handoff
and now you can try for free at
ziprecruiter.com ZipRecruiter uses its
powerful technology to find and match
the right candidate with your job you
can easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply Additionally you want to hear
the devil version will you play it
backwards this is
uh
has a complete Suite of tools that makes
it easier to filter review and rate your
candidates four to five employers
who post on zip is here uh get a quality
candidate within the first day so if
you're a fan of this podcast and want to
try zip yeah for free today you need to
remember our special URL
ziprecruiter.com once again that's zip
dot com slash b-u-r-r ZipRecruiter the
smartest way to hire oh and look who's
here in here these people Simply Safe
here's the question Nia is there
anything more precious than the safety
of you and your loved ones
Fashion Week honey sorry of course not
uh so isn't it strange that not all home
security systems truly put you first old
school home security systems set you up
with outdated technology over just
pictures one of those big wooden you
know like those TVs except it's a
security system
uh
got a revolver on top of it it's on you
[ __ ] good luck to you old school
home security companies set you up with
outdated technology overcharge you for
service and lock you into uh binding
multi-year contracts right it's like
Columbia Records and tapes except
they're protecting your family that's
why I use and Trust Simply Safe home
security Simply Safe protects you with
Cutting Edge security technology powered
by 24 7 Professional monitoring agents
who always have your back with 24 7
Professional monitoring Simply Safe
agents call you the moment a threat is
detected and dispatch police or First
Responders I thought the cops were First
Responders weren't they they're talking
about the emergent like the um
ambulances and the right are they not or
are they talking about I don't know what
the everything has been re-labeled
dispatch firefighters ambulance people
yes they're all paramedics crossing
guards meter maids the guys who get up
early and bake the croissants even if
you're not home or can't be reached
they're the real heroes okay they put
their rain boots on one boot at a time
they crawl off that hooker and put out
that cigar and get down there and
[ __ ] put out put out your
uh Simply Safe
Simply Safe blankets your home in
protection with Advanced sensors for
every room window and door HD security
cameras for inside and outside your
homes smarter ways to detect motions
that only alert you when a threat is
real and all right relax it's not real
and even he's hammocked he's at the
wrong house go back to sleep and even
sensors that instantly detect fires
floods and other threats to your home
our monitoring experts use proprietary
Advanced response technology to visually
confirm when a break-in is real so you
can get the highest priority police
dispatch customize the perfect system
for your home in just a few minutes at
simplysafe.com go to today and claim a
free indoor security camera plus 20 off
with interactive monitoring go to
simplysafe.com that's
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
uh there's no safe like simply safe
all right this is from Andrew females
Bill we got great emails please remind
the listeners of the podcast email it is
Monday Morning podcast at gmail.com
Monday Morning podcast at gmail.com
all right
um we got this is where you come in
there okay this is where you bring your
magic to the podcast and we decide if
you're coming back again next week oh
okay no pressure again it's been it's
been over a year so hey how come we're
getting along so great lately I know
I know we're having like a really we're
really connected I feel like you know
what it is what is it you I think you
finally realized how amazing I am okay
well maybe
[Music]
I thought you were gonna trash me that's
how well we're getting along you're not
even breaking my you're on here
the listeners want I've all I hear is my
voice they want to hear you trash me I
just got here give me a minute to warm
up all right you'll get it in a second
okay all right George Foster now just to
give you a a background uh George Foster
was one of my favorite players when I
was growing up I did a show in
Louisville I've been out there in
America Nia mm-hmm you know I've been
out there doing all them red states that
all all the blue liberals make fun of
right of all the states that once ours
is underwater they're going to be like
hey you know what I didn't think you
guys were that bad you know they're
gonna show up in their designer [ __ ]
working class clothes that's the movie I
want to see
oh now you like us don't you
wagging your finger at them Ward shows
why does everybody have a Southern
accent that isn't in New York and La
built because I'm limited
I'm limited
all right so George coach I can do
dialects I just have to be hanging out
with the person
oh okay you know I can actually do that
go ahead pick a dialect I'll do it okay
um let's see do a mid do a Midwestern
one oh hey Bob
go get a box and tell Tom to come over
here and get some pop
I mean I feel like it needs work but I
that was dead on was it that wasn't even
Chicago that was Milwaukee no I can't do
a Midwestern accent
um
I just know that they always we're gonna
slide into like the Fargo
oh that thing that's typically what I
feel like what people do you want to
hear a Canadian accent okay they gotta
get it up
what they gotta get it out they oh gotta
get it gotta get it out okay not oot oh
gotta get it out oh yeah so you got
every every American goes oot they don't
got to get out oh when you're watching
hockey and the puck has been in your
zone for too long and there's a Canadian
there
at some point the Canadian is going to
say they got to get it out
the first time I ever heard a Canadian
accent was on that show you can't do
that on television are you too old to
know what that is yeah yeah yeah so I
remember watching it I love that show
they talk so weird I like I didn't
understand that it was Canadian it was
different they were in a different
country I assume they were in America
because I was a kid so I was like why
are they saying the words like that you
know what a woman says in Canada when
you're banging her without a condom
you're almost ready to come what you
gotta get it
oh they're easy jokes over here at the
Monday Morning podcast all right uh
George Foster so I went to the uh the
Louisville Slugger Factory which I
absolutely 100 would do again it was
like that is a bat and you go in there
and they got the guys with the lathes
going and you watch them the lates
that's where the uh they they take a
little block of wood and smell it
oh God come on
Halloween's in th
um
so it's basically it's it's a machine
that just it it you put a like a piece
of wood in that Jesus Christ and you
know it's got like the pins on either
side you lock it in and then it spins
and then they carve okay so they're
carving the bat so they'll be like this
is Vladimir Guerrero Junior's bats and
then they'll hand you one that's like
raw they haven't finished it or anything
it's it's still like uh it's not all
smooth and it gets got like two little
blocks hanging on either side of it but
they'll hand you one
um and I gotta tell you like a lot of
them were surprisingly
like really light which now makes sense
because you want to get through the zone
as fast as you can but like
um the one that was like the heaviest
was uh so she said was uh Ted Williams
Ted Williams just had like literally
just like it was up there with like a
[ __ ] piece of lumber but anyways
George Foster when they asked me like
when they they brought us into this
place where they had all the prototypes
of their bats he had to put on gloves
before you put them on I said who do you
want and I was just like I'm not gonna
go with the hacky ones everybody says I
want somebody that was awesome but a
little obscure
um for younger people I said George
Foster and anyway
um so this person is writing in about
George Foster okay he played for the big
red machine and won a title in uh 75-76
75 beat the Red Sox one of the greatest
games ever played game six they won in
game seven and then they swept the New
York Yankees in 1976. okay
okay is that enough background yeah I
think I got it okay cool all right
George Foster dear Billy red balls uh
listening to your podcast about
Cincinnati and you mentioned George
Foster I worked at George sorry I worked
at Shea Stadium as a vendor [ __ ] beer
that's that that's Boston right New York
hey [ __ ] beer here
no that's not New York yeah and
all right you're doing New York accent
I'm I don't I don't think I'm gonna like
you know what you are good at
criticizing other people's attempts I
feel like I could do like a New York
girl like a Dominican like a Dominican
girl talking about you know like what
the [ __ ] is your problem you know maybe
something like that I don't know I I
don't wanna let's be honest we both need
to do a lot we both need some uh some
training when you say it and then you
immediately follow it with something
like that that's that's when you know
you need work it's bad it's kind of like
when people will try to do your like a
billboard impression in front of me it's
always so terrible and I just kind of
have to smile and be like there's a
couple that are good because I know
other comedians send them to me and I
refuse to watch them because I don't
need to know
I don't want to be like thinking like oh
I do do that when I'm talking so it gets
in your head too much if you see someone
do this impression of you
yeah or makes you like self-conscious
yeah because Ben Bailey used to imitate
me and go and he would always go for
some reason and you would always do that
and I I guess I would at that time I was
saying that a lot
and yes and then it got into my head and
I and I stopped doing it but like if
that's what I do that's what the [ __ ] I
don't want to get away from what it's
like Pete Rose you know you don't want
to change his swing that's what got you
to the dance all right uh
so it's all baseball references uh I
worked at Shea Stadium as event this is
when George Foster played for the Mets
and was there when George Foster played
for them Shea stadiums was the classic
no it's in New York I got it
wait Shea Stadium it's not in New York
yeah it's in Queens okay thank you all
right it was in Queens all right it's
the last place The Beatles played last
place the police played before they got
back together just read the question
this is why your podcast is like five
hours long the tangents my God the
tangent all right in those days the home
team had batting practice before the
fans were allowed in
now you can kind of go in and watch them
take bang press and he goes and it was
loose a loose fun time we got to know a
few of the players and old George was of
was [ __ ] funny he is tossing a ball
with somebody and Ebony and Ivory came
on you know the classic yeah ebony
and ivory and Ivory
you are blinders I have sights I have
sight
side by side
that's the only one that I remembered
because it's not fight yeah let's not
fight I could never get through the real
song of this Joe Piscopo shout out to
Joe Piscopo is that bad I could never
get to the first one it just used to
make me uncomfortable
two men being sentimental with each
other one of them missing a sense you
know just seemed too okay uh we got to
know a few of the players and old George
was [ __ ] funny he's tossing a ball
with someone and Ebony and Ivory came on
the radio he flips down his Shades miss
those they used to have the shades you
know for the sun uh and start swaying
like Stevie Wonder and yells throw me
the ball throw me the ball and he
promptly pretends he is blind and let's
whiz by him he yells it again and it's a
soft toss he allows it to bounce off his
chest and we're all cracking up uh no
more of that fun in the PC world we live
in yeah like why because he was white
imitating a black guy no he's black okay
oh oh because he was imitating a blind
guy yeah do we not do that with Stevie
wondering no we probably don't but I
remember that because no we we still do
it's just Nobody Does it okay yeah oh my
God and then people who aren't blind are
going to get offended for the blind
people you know who can't see us doing
it anyway exactly that's gonna be my
point
all right bye
why why are we offended you can't
[ __ ] see me doing it anyway
I can make fun of the death all I want
as long as I turn my back on them
like Society uh by the way I was
wondering game I was working game six
when old Billy B made that era Bill
Buckner and game seven was on
uh
uh as a Yankee fan I was happy as I made
a few extra bucks and [ __ ] the Red Sox
and [ __ ] the Mets whoa whoa whoa
whoa uh well maybe if you were [ __ ] a
little better they would have hired you
at Yankee Stadium instead of that dump
there [ __ ] the Red Sox let's let's calm
down here no that's fine well what's he
gonna say heading into what's he gonna
say I know that's true he's a Yankee fan
so I guess it is that's what he has to
say and then and then he has to bring up
go back in the past about how many
championships they won didn't that uh
because they haven't won let me finish
my [ __ ] talk here because they don't
[ __ ] win anymore now that there's 30
teams and everybody can [ __ ] play
they're not winning and I always thought
it was funny that Yankee fans in
particular always talk about how many
championships they have and I was
thinking like as a Celtics fan when I
was growing up I was never like we got
15 we got 16 you know like when like
when we would lose to the Lakers or
something you know I wouldn't be I
wouldn't you know yell at [ __ ] Laker
fans how many you know how many [ __ ]
championships we had it's so stupid it's
classic [ __ ] Yankee fits I was gonna
say I feel like they're I won't the
petty I won't say the name but Petty
wasn't you know a friend of ours who
came to see you a friend of us it sounds
very like Mafia wasn't there a friend of
ours who came to see you at Fenway and
he said he was going to wear his Yankees
and he decided not to oh yeah because
and he listens to this podcast oh does
he listens you know we're talking about
you the person who shall not be named
Petty is the perfect one here's the
thing if his team wasn't in first place
and we didn't suck he would not wear it
to the he would not he was wearing it to
[ __ ] rub it in there's Petty fans out
there I saw this actor on uh Rich Eisen
show was talking about when you know the
year the Cubs are going to win it they
were in the playoffs and they were
having a you know you know down to the
wire series before they got to the World
Series and he was a Cardinals fan and he
went to Wrigley and he goes and they all
got all mad that I was wearing my
Cardinals hat I mean I was just you know
I'm from St Louis I'm a baseball fan
it's like dude you know what the [ __ ]
you're doing because St Louis has won
all of these championships they're the
big rival with Chicago and they all know
that he's not rooting for them it was a
real it was real like [ __ ] uh I think
you're all I what is hilarious to me
about these fans versus these fans and
these fans like you're all [ __ ] nuts
to me all sports fans are just [ __ ]
crazy oh absolutely yeah so it's like
the Yankees versus the Red Sox and the
Patriots versus the I don't know who's
your big rival
Patriots wise
Giants or
well I'm always putting it into like New
York Boston no Giants was a Giants was a
thing when Brady and and um Eli were
there
that developed into this thing because
they beat us when we had an undefeated
record and then like I remember when we
were going to play him again like I had
like knots in my stomach going oh my God
if we lose to these guys again they're
gonna say all of this [ __ ] which they
ended up doing but then we won three
more so now it's like all right well I
are we going to talk about we won six
out of nine so that's why that kind of
doesn't like
there's few things there's there's some
things that like I would say the
Patriots the real rivalry that we had
was with the Colts because not only
did they have like Peyton Manning and
all of that they ran like a smear
campaign on us
um and we're just like constantly
complaining to the refs and I'm not
gonna go with my fans over this million
times complaining to the Reps helping to
change rules that gave you know made it
less advantation for us more advantages
for them while calling us cheaters
there's a great clip that just came out
on Twitter catching like they were they
were pumping crowd noise in Indianapolis
and the [ __ ] tape skipped oops
so it was a real Millie vanilla moment
yeah they're the Millie van well I would
say that but like now um
Nate Craig this weekends was saying
um
we have you know instead of having we
have the loudest fan base in the league
it's now we have the loudest DJ because
the sound systems are just so it's so
crazy loud like I I bring [ __ ]
earplugs like I'm gonna go see uh I want
to talk AC DC about you don't have to
point at me I want to know I want to
talk to you about this Brady situation
that he's in right now we're talking
about they won this week they won this
no I'm talking about the fact that like
he said he was gonna retire and now he's
not and now he's getting a divorce
see is that why the WNBA doesn't make it
excuse me what are you talking about
well because you guys are into that I
don't give a [ __ ] that's his uh that's
his personal life I know and he's going
through a really painful thing right now
and that guy put my [ __ ] team on the
goddamn map times six I'm not talking
talk about it in the wrong podcast oh
really this is the wrong podcast talk
about it because let me tell you
something right now if you made it let
me tell you something let me know if you
made me move to Tampa okay well you did
your you know job obviously I don't
think that was his idea
um what do you mean well she's from
Brazil isn't she gradually dragging him
back to Brazil like when a crocodile
grabs somebody no one's dragging anybody
the alligator catches to the [ __ ]
cleaners
no they're both Rich come on no no she
doesn't know she doesn't need his money
oh now we're all precious about Brady he
doesn't even give a [ __ ] about New
England anymore he's already done with
you guys he's over over you he should be
Boston he should be why are you being so
level-headed I thought we're gonna be
able to like have a little back and
forth about it because all
anti-patriot fans I'm not an anti-page
whatever the [ __ ] you are coming at me
whatever is you guys all want you guys
all want me to hate that guy because he
went to Tampa that guy took us to nine
[ __ ] Super Bowl and won six of them
all right we have we're tied for the
most championship Super Bowls ever
[ __ ] won with
the Steelers you know and everybody
knows that Green Bay is the [ __ ]
Celtics Yankees Lakers Canadians of of
football because they they don't count
NFL titles I don't know why but what
that guy didn't I don't give a [ __ ] man
if if you got to the point where you
couldn't deal with their coach and you
want to go down to Florida and not pay
[ __ ] state taxes who gives a [ __ ]
like that guy should have [ __ ]
retired if he was regular before we won
the last [ __ ] three and he hung in
there and we won another three I don't
give a [ __ ] what that guy does God bless
him fair enough he could go play for the
Giants and win 10. I don't give a [ __ ]
because I the the guy made me happy for
two decades yeah I guess so all right
you know what it was like being a
[ __ ] Patriots fan before the well
Bledsoe came in Parcels that was
exciting and everything but we still
never quite got over the hump and then
Parcells told the team he was selling
this [ __ ] house allegedly right
before we played the Packers in the
Super Bowl check why the [ __ ] would you
do that give us a chance man you're a
better [ __ ] coach than them still
kills me I went to that game cost me
[ __ ] two grand
um Okay so
so Brady just making a note in my phone
no I feel bad anybody I see going
through a divorce I always feel bad for
that [ __ ] and I don't think like it's
just something that I should [ __ ]
gossip about because uh you know I'm
having a slow goddamn morning all right
you do like the tea I do like the tea
but we can move on all right no you will
you know best of luck to you Tom Brady
yeah both of them they got kids together
that's going to be painful it's just
like that's like why not Charlie Sheen
was going off the [ __ ] rails and I
would be mourning DJ hey what do you
think about that I think his dad and his
brothers are all [ __ ] worried about
him I think it was more about the to me
like the exploring the Dynamics of that
marriage you don't talk about
all right I'm being a little precious I
mean a little
I love how you felt about I felt more
like of the Dynamics of the idea of like
you retiring and then being like
[ __ ] Brady like you're gonna be
taking some time off and if you were
like no I'm not doing that anymore I
would be like what you just said that
you were you know so I would feel some
type of way but maybe that's the
beginning and the end of the discussion
no no I want to know why does that
aspect of it Fascinate You
that like him starting to retire or not
because I'm trying to imagine as his
partner you're thinking and obviously I
don't know like the inner workings of
their relationship but I'm thinking okay
cool you're gonna be home more we're
gonna be doing more stuff with the kids
it's not gonna I supported you
throughout this whole entire time which
of course I'm happy to do because I'm
your wife but now our Dynamic is going
to be different and I'm excited for that
new Dynamic for you to be less busy for
you to be home more and then for you to
renege on that because you can't let go
of this career that you've already
proven yourself at for years renege
isn't it I wouldn't say that word is a
white guy
[Laughter]
but then but like the the the pull of
the game your career again when you've
already been celebrated and decorated in
it many times how many championships did
he win
uh he has seven there yeah like proving
yourself seven times like it doesn't get
any bigger than that and you're telling
me now you want to be you want to retire
go out on a high note be with us and now
you're being pulled back like that's I'm
gonna take that [ __ ] personally okay can
I just stop you for a second no no no no
I'm still going I'm gonna take that [ __ ]
personal
because now it's like you don't so you
really didn't want to do that oh you
really want to go back you really want
to be gone more can I just say one thing
no I'm not done yet and I'm just feeling
like no no I'm really done
you just built so much into that what do
you mean you you you had of course
because I'm not in it and so I know but
we don't know that that's what that's
what happened but this is not based on
the facts of what happened this is what
the emotion of it brings out this is
what gossip is Gossip is a way for
people to have a sports fan I know what
gossip is to do like shared values sort
of talking about you know it's very
rarely about the actual situation it's
about how you would do in that and that
in turn is about a bigger feeling about
whatever the issue is family Dynamics
husband and wife Dynamics career all
that kind of stuff but I already know
you you're never gonna retire you say
that you're like I'm gonna retire you're
not you're gonna be like you're gonna
have a DOT I'm calling it right now
you're gonna have a Don Rickles type of
vibe and you're gonna be doing these
really interesting movie roles well into
your 80s watch
I I don't know listen you heard it here
first folks this is and this is we're
already in an hour I know I know let's
move on no no it's sorry that I can
answer yeah like I don't even know what
the [ __ ] happened there all right I saw
something about
that the bottom one sisters what Sister
Wives
bill I got into an argument with the guy
at work about Sister Wives I'm guessing
that's uh it's got to be a series you
have to see it it is oh my God it's
based on a Mormon practice where they
have you know their polygamy or whatever
and they have many wives and they call
them Sister Wives so do you know what
the initial what they share a husband
they initially were gonna show they were
gonna call that show a bunch of [ __ ]
what
anyway keep reading
you moved out to Utah got himself a
bunch of [ __ ] uh
bill I got into an argument with a guy
at work about bunch of [ __ ] about
Sister Wives he told me that it would be
great as long as they get along
Sister Wives don't mean wives or sisters
it means okay because I say what the
[ __ ] it means that they'll they all
agree to being one of many wives
he told me that it's the perfect way to
have variety
with your Sage wisdom can you see any
benefits of having multiple wives well
this is interesting timing okay
it was interesting timing it's just
interesting timing that this
time what are you talking
nothing
second so do you see any benefit to
having multiple would you like to have
more than one wife
more than one wife I was gonna say no no
what are you doing for our birthday my
birthday
this is all you got me you got your
other 30 wives this bill doesn't want
another wife but
um perhaps
yeah I mean it's a mother variety some
other variety that came over there yeah
why not
why not
I'm gonna turn into that guy who's that
guy who's in The Sports World he goes I
want to see you with her
I want to I want to see her enjoying you
I will see you enjoying her
yeah it is the whole thing it's one of
those things the idea of it is fantastic
yes the actuality of doing it nightmare
yeah then it's it's yeah it's all in
your [ __ ] head it all seems like it's
gonna be great it's like going to
Disneyland you're like oh my God this is
going to be the happiest place on Earth
here's the thing you go there and you're
standing in line and it's a [ __ ]
nightmare I actually but when you're on
the ride
listen I think multiple wives is not a
terrible idea because then like she can
deal with you when I'm like not in the
you know just pass her off
and when and that like you're not in the
mood like to bang are you like not in
the mood to listen to myself to listen
to your [ __ ] just like I'm just like
annoyed with you call the bullpen yeah
you take
so you can you can take this load off of
me yeah literally literally
fake it
but yeah so I I understand it
I get it but I feel like though if
they're all if they're gonna be jealous
and stuff like that's a whole that's a
whole other thing you know it's like I
wanted him tonight yeah because I want
him tonight but they probably all like
do stuff together don't you think
I actually think what ends up happening
is you guys all collectively get sick of
each other the same way you would on a
one-on-one okay and then I feel like he
has to PL I don't mean I don't know what
rights women have in Utah and barely any
okay as a Mormon one because I think a
lot and the whole idea is to have as
many children as possible because
there's gonna be all that burden on one
body so you have many wives so that you
can have many children and you know your
your wife isn't miserable and Pregnant
for 20 years
but then there's like I like how you're
looking at all these other women like
personal assistants
um no I I think it's like
there's gonna be the one wife that you
Vibe with
that gets you and you get her and
there's no way the other ones aren't
gonna feel like some sort of uh
that there's like you know there's a
depth chart on the team here and why is
she the number one quarterback and all
that or maybe that's what you have to
have understood this is like it's like a
pimp game no right it's not what it is
you have your bottom [ __ ] and all of
that I watch HBO documentaries yeah well
I understand that pimps up hose down and
like 95 and no Patrice O'Neal gave me
that book Iceberg Slim no the whole
practice is barbaric and sexist and I'm
actually not I'm I'm joking when I say
like oh I get it no I think the whole
thing is like disgusting you know but in
terms of like having some other fairy
tale world yeah in a fairy tale world
yes I would like to pass you off to
somebody every now and again so I don't
have to deal with you I mean I'm just
being honest
am I that annoying everybody is annoying
everyone is annoying to their partner
I'm annoying to you you're I would not
pass you off to some other dude all
right well yeah sure yeah that would not
be happening
and shoes dude I understand it you know
I mean he needs to talk to you more
you want to go over to chicken cavas and
we can talk some more about it I think
I'm talking about more about like
periodic breaks than I feel like a
Sister Wives situation would be but it's
probably not like that I think they're
all together I thought we were getting
along great
um
all right I think that that's it this is
hour and five minutes so I have oh Score
says the article let's let's do this one
okay oh and I also have to give a shout
out to this guy in Bloomington Indiana
who did a a freehand sketch of me then I
thought yeah I thought it was great and
it was hilarious because oh that's cool
oh you did yeah yeah yeah
um he was working the front desk at the
hotel
oh wow no it's funny uh well I don't
want to say what he said because I don't
get anybody in trouble but like just
people talk to me you know how they talk
to me yeah you know but it's funny
because you're at workplace so yeah like
I'm not saying this person in Indiana
didn't do this uh-huh but people out of
the workplace they like dropped the
whole like they'll be dressed up like oh
hey welcome to Zelda and then hey Billy
red nuts yeah yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] hilarious all right uh I
the amount of times too like I remember
um
a few times I've been doing uh shooting
scenes and whatever I'm doing where I
got the street or something like that
and some of them will just buy like a
car will just drive by be like you just
hear like this guy just go hey go hey go
[ __ ] yourself yourself I'll just be like
hey how's it going or whatever and I
remember everyone's looking around like
wow who would cursing somebody like that
yeah
no I remember I forget what job I was on
but the actor in it when she was going
like she's going like a lot of your fans
just like yell at you say mean things to
you I go yeah I know it's a podcast
thing but yeah whatever that is I mean
that's like him saying hello uh
Scorsese article um
hey Bill I love a contrarian argument in
fact I think calling someone a
contrarian for their point of view is
usually just a way to qualify
uh is that what qualify their take as
flimsy and insincere
um it depends on how you use it if if I
just say you know yes and you say no and
I go oh you're just a contrarian yeah
that is but I mean if you're
consistently doing that over and over
because I was talking about how
um I feel like certain people do that
always have the opposite opinion of the
group it's a narcissistic thing it's
their way to keep the conversation on
them like what well how can you not like
how paella mode or whatever it's always
like something like really obvious like
I like air I don't like air well this
means you don't like air it's those
people who are like well Devil's
Advocate it's like I I do hate when
people do that because first of all the
devil doesn't need an advocate and
secondly not every
topic needs to be explored from all
angles in order to understand it some
[ __ ] is right and some [ __ ] is wrong so
I feel like it's very insincere to do
the whole like oh Devil's Advocate thing
it's like why that's the first time I
actually thought about that expression
Deadpool's Advocate like you're
advocating for the devil yeah you're
advocating for like you know sort of
what's widely considered probably to be
like the wrong point of view or like the
immoral point of view or whatever it is
and it's like my wife is smart
um yeah so that's my thing like if if I
just yeah you can definitely call
somebody a contrarian as it's a way of
bailing out
um
uh that was like that Jordan peel sketch
that I saw the other day the [ __ ]
crack oh yeah yeah
anyways guys yeah tell us how you really
feel okay
he was making no points awkward yeah
what I love about that though is it
totally takes what the other person is
saying it just takes the wind out yep
yep in other news
you know we're going to start doing that
to each other yeah anyway
um I would say I you know I got uh I
can't say why I'm coming up but we were
talking about Brian Jordan Albert
Alvarez
splashing splashing splashing it is my
life when I go into the water water with
my wife I [ __ ] love that guy
um follow him on Instagram please he's
so funny that's my favorite character I
like the I like the uh the aunt that has
all the houses but I do like that guy
because this this is something like
there's almost a sadness to him and he's
just anybody looks to the side he sort
of like contemplating his situation you
have you have if you don't follow him
just follow him so you know we're
talking about yeah it's so funny I love
that [ __ ] okay all right so anyway it's
also a way for people to shove the
official the official story down your
throat oh God see this person is like
arrogant yeah and just like oh here's
just too much okay already yeah I always
want to hear different takes on
established true you can quote as you
would say having said that as you would
say yeah that guy is like he he's medium
annoying but if he gets a couple of
glasses in him he's [ __ ] insufferable
and insufferable that was the word
uh that's what I'm getting out of that
okay maybe I'm just being a contrarian
uh there was an article going around by
a Critic who called scorsese's films
inconsistent and self-indulging
uh this is what happens if you hang
around too look all of a sudden
these movies are [ __ ] amazing Twitter
was in an uproar of course few seem to
agree with the man who wrote it but it
didn't seem to stop people attacking
Scorsese with proxy arguments like he's
a sexist filmmaker
um
these people are even worse than the guy
who wrote the article I'm sick of people
piling on because they can yeah social
media loves doing that it brings me back
to the idea that you can't challenge
people's minds and most people oh change
people's minds and most people have no
rational thinking capabilities so so
this is the part where your point of
view goes out the window because now
you're using it as a way to insult
people so that's the part of it that is
an issue with the contrarian because I
feel like they're just like low-key just
trying to undermine they're not
necessarily trying to present a
different point of view they're actually
trying to undermine so this person who
feels like Scorsese is inconsistent and
self-indulgent I don't think that they
are a contrarian I just think that they
are just to me that's click bait like
let's get people stirred up yeah and
also like they just may not be into
Scorsese and I people saying like he's a
sexist filmmaker I love Scorsese films
but I can understand why they would say
that when you think about the female
characters in all of his films I kind of
get it but I still I still that's what I
say like what which ones I'm thinking
about
Casino I'm thinking about Good Fellas
I'm thinking about what else am I
missing
again they weren't going to get good
women they were gangsters right so well
but so they had to be an element of dumb
broad in there well that's the thing
because it's just one particular View
and it has been what about uh what about
what's your face a taxi driver
the the child prostitute no not her oh
that he rescues civil Shepherd yeah he
was shining light on human trafficking I
don't know about that
um but you don't think so I don't I
don't know but I think it's they're
either like Madonna or Horrors so I feel
like that in itself is pretty sexist so
I get it but again I love I think that's
a generational thing I think that's how
he was and it probably is and probably a
hundred percent is but I love Casino
that's one of my favorite movies of all
time and I love Sharon Stone in that
film because I found her to be
complicated and layered and I like
Sharon Stone should have got a [ __ ]
Oscar for that I think she no and if no
it's because everybody's up in arms
because uh you know she showed a hoo-ha
and [ __ ] uh bending over the couch
whatever that [ __ ] movie was called
basic instant bend me over the couch yep
that's you that's classic builtmore
that's classic you not remembering the
name I know but I I just throw out the
first thing that I think of I just
remember and that was Jean triple horn
being bent over a couch for no [ __ ]
reason I mean she was basically raped in
that scene it was pretty bad
that scene yeah
don't you remember when we were watching
yeah wait a minute is he and I was like
kinda no but they Justified it that she
was why was she wearing thigh highs
I mean yeah why do they make any of
those decisions that they did yeah let's
let's not get a bunch of bored people
stirred up about a movie that happened
30 years ago and get some 80 year old
producer I know let's get them started
off about how I'm on the podcast again
Yes again
oh [ __ ] all those [ __ ] exactly
um yeah anyway that's yeah that's what
it is that's what this [ __ ] business
is people [ __ ] give me like no matter
what you do you get [ __ ] and it is a
good thing if you want to be successful
just know no matter what you put out
there there's going to be a bunch of
people doing the what
um yeah who gives a [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] to them meanwhile you'll be selling
tickets and uh living your best life all
right you want me here that's the most
important thing well I did until you
told me you wouldn't mind having another
couple of guys around to take a break
from me or women around
women around right exactly let's be
clear
well listen there I can be honest with
you you're not I you're easy to get
along with from me you really are Oh I
thought you're gonna say you're no pony
ride yourself no
I mean as much as it hurts sometimes
when like you marry somebody that isn't
as smart as you wow one of the upsides
is that you can easily manipulate them
um yeah well I'm gonna end this podcast
I'm gonna tell you what we're doing
today all right everybody because I'm
running the show all right that's the
podcast the lovely Nia looking lovely as
always thank you uh thank you guys for
listening and I will check in on you on
Thursday I got a couple I got another
great guest another great guest you
should listen this Thursday if it's the
guy I think I mean you should all of
them are great but uh there's one that
you actually know okay that we haven't
seen in a while that got on and he was
extra silly and I know how much you love
silly I love silly Silly's awesome all
right